HIGHLIGHT!
BAD MAN.
TURNER.
PUTS IT ON THE TURNER.
THROWING IT DOWN WITH TWO.
EXCELLENT JOB ON THE DURANT!
THE GIVE, THE 14MENT
HARDEN TO LOOK AT THIS.
OF L.
DURANT, OVER TWO.
THAT'S N
DURANT LINES ITF A
BROOKLYN.
WE' SEASON. AND HE'S AWARE
WHERE PAUL MILLSAP IS GOING TO
BE.T PUTS THE LEGGER, SO SMOO,
THE FOUL. KICK.
MILLS BOOK IT,
STRUGGLING IN THE FOULED.
ONCE HE
THE CLOCK.
DEFENSE,
A CUT THROUGH TWO PLAYERS. TO.
KEVIN ABLE TO EMB
GOT FOULED.
STILL PUTS IT IN!
STEPS UP, DRAINS IT, GETS TO TE
LILI
>> ONE OR HAD
A BOWED.
LOST
JOHNSON AND THE NETS WITH THE
GETS
OFFENSIVELY.
>> Doris: YES, SWINGS IT.
DURANT AGAINST
KICK, DURANT THAT WAS A
THE FI.
KEVIN DURANT WITH A A 25-POIN,
8 REBOUND PERFORMANCE, RISING
HAYWARD, SWINGS IT IN, OFF TH
OPENING QUARTER.
GRIFFIN IS WAY OUTSIDE AGAINST
THIS BLOCK.
PATTY RAN HIM DOWN
WE
>> Reggie: YOU SEE THE OFFEN IN
THIRD.
>> Reggie: ONLHE OTHER.
BEAUTIFUL PASS BY OUT.
EURO-STEPPING AND- THAT'S A
GREAT READ BY FEET LIKE THAT.
>> Joel: KEVIN DURANT,
DURANT.
A CHANCE FOROR